dafür setze ich kein quatsch männer aus
europa und anderen westlichen regionen
produzieren immer weniger spermien gar
nicht gut
die spermienanzahl pro milliliter
samenflüssigkeit ist in den vergangenen
40 jahren um mehr als 50 prozent
gesunken berichten jetzt medizinerinnen
und mediziner aus jerusalem und new york
was genau jetzt unseren spanien so zu
und bedeutet dieses ergebnis jetzt eine
gefahr für und westliche männer oder
sogar für die ganze menschheit das alles
erfahrt ihr jetzt mit blick zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
in der analyse der forscherinnen und
forscher aus new york und jerusalem sind
ganze 224 spermien zählungen aus 185
studien einbezogen
die innerhalb der letzten 40 jahre an
knapp 43.000 männern durchgeführt worden
waren also eine wirkliche riesige
datenbasis und das ergebnis ihrer
analyse die wie im fachmagazin human
reproduction update veröffentlicht haben
ist beunruhigend ein drastischer
rückgang der spermien bei männern aus
europa australien neuseeland und
nordamerika pro samenerguss haben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
einen rückgang der spermien gesamtzahl
von knapp 60 prozent errechnet pro
milliliter samenflüssigkeit sei die
spermienanzahl um mehr als 50 prozent
gesunken
das klingt schon wirklich nicht so gut
keine signifikanten veränderungen konnte
das forscherteam dagegen beim männer aus
anderen weltregionen wie asien afrika
und südamerika feststellen das ergebnis
ist gras und klingt irgendwie auch
besorgniserregend überraschend und neu
ist diese erkenntnis allerdings nicht
denn schon seit jahrzehnten gibt es
immer mehr hinweise darauf dass etwas
unserem spermien schwer zusetzt so gibt
es eine wirklich große zahl an studien
aus verschiedenen ländern die den selben
schluss nahelegen die zahl der
männlichen samen geht zurück zudem
steigt der anteil von nicht normal
reformen in spanien zuletzt hatte ein
französisches forscherteam daten aus
einer langzeitstudie veröffentlicht nach
denen die spermienproduktion um zwei
prozent abnehme pro jahr
dieses ergebnis deckt sich in etwa mit
der jetzt veröffentlichten studie aus
jerusalem und new york deren analyse
einen jährlichen rückgang der schwärmen
anfang pro milliliter samenflüssigkeit
von 14 prozent bei westlichen man keine
angabe zu gehen dann zeigt aber was
genau ist die ursache für den spermien
schon das lässt sich aus den studien
leider nicht ablesen ist es stress
medikamente oder übergewicht aber auch
handystrahlung oder chemikalien die
beispielsweise in weichmacher oder
pflanzenschutzmitteln stecken und den
hormonhaushalt beeinflussen könnten den
spermien zu setzen all diese aspekte
stehen tatsächlich im verdacht und
werden nicht erst seit der aktuellen
studie aus new york und jerusalem
heftig diskutiert konsens in der
fachwelt also übereinstimmung besteht
aber darüber dass wärme dem kühlsystem
der hoden und damit auch der sperma
produktion schreiben kann wer plant ein
kind zu zeugen kann durch den verzicht
auf enge unterhosen warme bäder
saunagänge und sitzheizung seine
schwärmer qualität positiv beeinflussen
als wissenschaftlich gesichert gilt auch
das rauchen den spermien schade der
studienleiter aus jerusalem h glühwein
versieht seine ergebnisse als zitat
dringenden legkow für forscher und
gesundheitsbehörden auf der ganzen welt
ja und tatsächlich wissen wir alle
für die männliche fruchtbarkeit wind
spermien unabdingbar und von
unschätzbarem wert auch wenn solche
ergebnisse die gesundheitsbehörden
sicherlich aufhorchen lassen einen grund
zur panik sehen reproduktionsmediziner
trotzdem nicht denn die konkreten zahlen
liegen immer noch weit über den werten
die die weltgesundheitsorganisation whu
als untergrenze zur zeugungsfähigkeit
angibt die untergrenze des normalbereich
liegt bei der spermien gesamtzahl von 39
millionen
laut aktuellen studien betrug sie im
jahr 2011 bei westlichen männern achtung
ohne kinder nachweis bei 107 5 millionen
abgesehen von der spermien anfang ist
zudem ihre beweglichkeit und ob sie eine
normale form oder fehlbildung aufweisen
von großer bedeutung beide faktoren
wurden in der aktuellen studie jetzt
nicht wirklich ich dennoch die aktuelle
studie bestärkt den trend der
kontinuierlich nachlassenden
spermienanzahl in den letzten
jahrzehnten das studienergebnis legt
außerdem nach dafür mit den
lebensumständen in den westlichen
industrienationen zu tun hat denn wie
sonst kann es sein dass bei männern aus
anderen regionen dieser welt keine
unterschiede zu früher festgestellt
worden wird es wartet also für den mann
selbst und auch für die menschheit
besteht aktuell keine gefahr wohlgemerkt
aktuell dennoch ist es wichtig dass wir
brauchen bleiben um möglichst schnell
die ursache für unseren spermien schwund
zu identifizieren pixum halte ich euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn ihr
kein video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
sollten wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesslich den
genau auf den glockner hier geht es
weiter mit sex und liebe chemie da geht
es um die chemie die nötig ist bevor es
überhaupt zum samenerguss kommen kann
aber sehr interessant nichtverpackungen
unbedingt darauf liegen ansonsten bis
dann bleib dran und viel spaß bei dem
video